CBS News legal analyst for keek Lehman
is with us so Oh Jay Simpson will appear
via videoconference what does he need to
demonstrate to the parole board remorse
of course and what you have will have
for parole board members they'll have
mr. Simpson they will have a
question-and-answer session he must show
not only why he is sorry for what he did
but he must show he is rehabilitated
from what he did you do that yes he can
- no no how do you do that how do you do
that he can do that by just taking
responsibility which he did in 2013 in
addition you have other witnesses you
have the victim in this case who is
prepared to testify in favor of Simpsons
parole he also needs to show what are
his plans for the future you know they
don't let people out willy-nilly where
are you going to live how are you going
to support yourself who's gonna be there
for you and he has the ability to do
that with the person who is coming to
say he'll live with him and his family
he's my bless have been a model prisoner
they say model prisoner indeed there is
a graph this is done by status and by
dynamic factors there were our eleven
factors that Board considers it's a grid
and by all estimation the lower your
score the lower your risk any person in
his situation the percentages are that
82 percent of people in Nevada will get
paroled at toward their minimum sentence
his is a minimum of 9 to a maximum of 33
were they in his situation how long will
it take us to get a decision very fast
we were going to have a hearing they'll
recess briefly and then they will come
back with a decision thank you so much
thank you thank you here we'll bring you
live coverage of the parole here excuse
me in a CBS News special report
this scheduled to begin at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern noon Central